welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for today's
presentation titled
agilent lc-ms released glycan workflow
it's my pleasure to introduce dr
christopher colangelo
biopharma business development leader
for agilent technologies
for a complete biography on our speaker
you can visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if you have questions that arise during
the presentation we encourage you to
submit them in the q a box
our speaker will be addressing questions
following the presentation
so please join me in welcoming dr
colangelo i'll now turn the presentation
over to him
well thank you um thanks for joining us
today
uh i'm going to spend time talking about
n-linked release glycan workflows from
agilent
and primarily of using automation
from chromatography separation and lcms
for the detection and the analysis
so when we think about glycans and maybe
you've heard some of the earlier talks
that the role of glycans play we know
how important they are
in both uh monoclonal antibodies
in vaccines and even in therapeutics
or even controlling uh translation and
transcription they're involved in those
processes as well
so the importance of this kit is
obviously
well understood but what's even more
important is as we make
protein therapeutics we need to
understand
what glycans we're putting on there and
ideally in mammalian systems we can put
a wide range of glycan structures as
shown
on the right hand side of this slide and
due to that
through the wide range of structures
that when you produce a molecule
that you're going to give a therapeutic
you're not producing just one molecule
you're producing a heterogeneous mixture
of molecules that have a variety of
different glycogen structures
so understanding the distribution of
these glycan structures
on your molecules is really important
for regulatory guidance
the other neat thing about glycoproteins
is that
95 percent of of the proteins
are made up of amino acids that are five
percent is glycan
and the same thing applies when you
think about the human genome is that
actually five percent of all the genes
code for processes
involved in glycation so you can see the
important role it plays
in understanding this and today we're
going to talk about tools you can use to
understand what structures are on your
protein or therapeutic or even vaccine
and how to efficiently do that
so if we think about uh looking at
glycans there's two ways of doing it
first is either do it intact on the
glycoform
right where you have the entire
monoclonal antibody shown here your
protein therapeutic
and you're actually just going to look
at the intact mass and
look at it i'm not going to focus on
that today you can actually go listen to
rebecca glasgow my colleague
dr glaskin's talk and she'll go
specifically into our tools used to
detect and identify intact glycoforms
where i'm going to focus my time today
is on the release glycos
on the right hand side of this slide
and specifically when we do release
glycans we have a really wonderful
reagent
from agilent called instant pc and i'll
go through that reagent you might have
heard it earlier if you listen to some
of these other talks
and i'll explain why that uh reagent is
used to actually derivatize these
release glockens
and then makes it easier to detect in a
mass spectrometer
as well as increase the fluorescence
detection
as i said earlier agilent and what we
like to think of
we don't like to think of an individual
product we actually like to think of an
entire workflow
that actually will bring you success
when you want to do these applications
we have a lot of biologists that come
into working with us
that want to look at glycans or even
geneticists that say hey i'm starting to
think about making a protein or
therapeutic
and i need to be able to understand its
glycation
so instead of saying okay you can go out
and find someone who's really good at
lcms you can find someone else as good
as separation or even a data
analysis scientist the goal for us is to
give you
tools from step a from sample prep all
the way through
step z which is servicing your
instrument so that you can robustly day
after day
week after week year after year do this
in a relative manner and i think that's
really important that you know the
consistency of
columns the consistency of our data
software consisting our service as well
as our tips into sample prep
matter so that the results you collect
today are the same results you're going
to get in six months
and that's important about setting up
workflows it's not just doing it once
and publishing it's doing it day after
day after day
especially when you're talking about
giving therapeutics to
other humans or even potentially if
you're doing it in the
veterinary space so as we think about
the workflow
that we're going to use for release
glycans there's basically
four steps and those steps start over
here
on the left side with sample prep and in
sample prep
we can use a system called the acid map
bravo i'll get a little bit into that
um and we have specific kits with lyco
prep kits from instant pc
all that specifically work with this uh
assay map bravo to make sample
preparation
uh easy and streamline i'll get into
that secondly we have a separation
component where we're using uh plc to
separate
all the release glycans third part is
actually detecting it and i'm going to
show you a qtof one of our
bio cutoffs called the 6545xt advanced
bio-qtof
and why that's a really wonderful system
and some of the tuning features we have
that really
help you detect these glycans especially
lava glycans
and finally it wouldn't be complete
unless we have a comprehensive
software solution to actually look and
find these glycogens identify them as
well as give you some quantitative
information
so starting with step one the asymptote
so what makes the agilent asthma problem
just like a wonderful choice for
users who want to do sample prep for all
types of protein materials you can even
do nucleic acids on these type of
products
well first it's built off our bravo
liquid handling robot
and the nice thing about the bravo
liquid handling robot is that it's
extremely small and compact it actually
fits into a fume hood
or bl cabinet if you're going to do
viral type work
additionally it's got interchangeable
heads you can not only use this specific
assay map head that we're using but you
can actually put on other heads like a
96 while heading the 380
or we'll have to do other type of work
down the road some other groups are
using it
right now to do sample prep pcr type
prep for covet testing so it's that kind
of flexibility that
labs are looking at now the second part
that makes it really interesting the
assay map head that you put on
specifically has these
microchromatography cartridges
that allow you to do microchromatography
and because you can do a
microchromatography you can actually
control the flow
you can also control the binding and
actually see the illusion in a very very
small volume
so you can load up a hundred microliters
of material through this
cartridge but elude often five
microliters and that's an enrichment of
20-fold
so it's just a great uh type of media
and it's got wonderful
binding capacity we used to be able to
bind uh
only up to a hundred micrograms of
capacity but now we have newer columns
that actually go up to 500 micrograms of
total protein
so really wonderful cartridges and
lastly
the part that makes this super easy is
that it has a graphical software and i
like to think of it
like an app store if you want to do
release glycans you click on the app for
release glycos and it walks you through
it tells you exactly
on the deck and the plate of where to
put your things
what plates to use and where to put your
solutions and it even gives you
calculations on how to make up your
buffers it does everything for you
so again it's you don't need to have an
automated person who
builds a big robot and makes a specific
where to go when
and it only works for that assay you can
do that
uh stream streamline for you and the
ascii map is not only going to allow you
to do end
link and glycan sample prep which is
shown right in the center
uh on the bottom of the slide it allows
you to do all these other types of
assays as well whether it be antibody
purification whether it be trypsin
digestion
or pg and sf digestion we're going to
show you it also lets you do
phosphopeptide enrichment so groups that
are doing proteomics
groups that are looking to enrich
specifically for signaling
signal transduction molecules can use
that
um you can use amino affinity
purification so if you're growing cell
cultures
and you want to trap protein a protein g
to do a clonal selection you can use it
on this platform
so all these become relatively easy
they're clicked links just like you
would download an app
and additionally you can also do
reactions on here and that's sort of
what we're going to show here in our
procedure we're actually going to bind
it and then use pgnsf to actually cleave
off the glycans we're going to do it on
cartridge
reaction so the glycoprep
and link sample preparation it takes a
little bit longer
than our i'll show about another
labeling where you can actually do a
bench top
which you can do at 45 to 45 minutes to
an hour this takes about four
five hours but it it does it unintended
and that's the difference between the
earlier one we can do 45 minutes we have
to spend all your time here you just set
it up and forget it
so that's one of the advantages of this
this system is that you can set it and
additionally
since the pipetting is being done with a
with an automated liquid handling system
you know the reproducibility from day
one
to you know infinity is always going to
be the same
additionally if you're thinking about
doing this manually
like with microfuges or plate formats
or the traditional way i did in grad
school right when i did 2a b labeling
it took multiple days with dry down
steps that it's two to three days each
would take to do this kind of prep
so you'd start on monday and then you'd
be collecting your data on thursday
now you can start first thing in the
morning and buy lunch you can have your
samples on
and by the end of the day have your
results
so the other thing is these kits are
compatible with our instant pc dies
we'll talk a little about instant a b
we also have um an apts die for those
customers looking to do ce as well i'm
not going to spend any time on c
but we can clearly use c as a as a
method to look at release collections as
well
so we have a variety of different dies
and this sort of shows your labeling
choices and the one highlighted here is
the instant pc and that's the one i'm
going to mostly focus on
today and the reason why is it gives you
both a wonderful strong fluorescent
signal
and a strong ms signal traditionally we
used to use 2ab that's what i use in
grad school
and um the 2ab does reductive amination
it's a nice molecule it separates really
well when you use a
helix but the difficulty is that it's
fluorescence
okay and it's mass spec signal is really
poor
um we've actually taken that same dye
and made it into an instant dye called
the instant baby
and the benefit of that is it speeds up
the reaction but again
it's great for fluorescence but not
exceptional
for mass spec and that's sort of where
the instant pc because it does both of
them really well
so and here's where i'm talking about
basically the sample
preparation types you can choose again
the glycoprep
kits that we can put on the automated
systems you can do to four to five hours
if you use traditional dies
about three hours if you use the instant
dies and if you want to use a
plate based format with this goliax
these newer kits
but it's all manually done that with
those instant dies you can do actually
under an hour
so you got your choices and
flexibilities and sort of here's the
plate-based format with a vacuum
manifold and depending on the samples
can take you
like we said 45 minutes to 120 minutes
to do that depending on the load and the
sample
directly now the first step of any type
of
reduction and doing this glycan sample
prep will be easy to donate to your
protein that's pretty easy
take your protein you denature it uh at
90 degrees to open it up and unfold it
so now you can actually have
access to those glycan
sites the second part is is the
glycosylation
and this is an area i wanted to spend a
little bit of time on because
as agilent we make a wonderful pg sf
and it's really important that we've
spent a huge amount of time
formulating this pg nsf to be extremely
rapid
what we call rapid pg nsf that in five
minutes we can achieve 99
or greater release glycans and here's a
variety of different
uh monoclonal antibodies from enbro to
rituximab
and you can see all these have greater
than 99
um nucleic oscillation in only five
minutes
and there's a control on an enzyme sort
of showing that data i think that's
really important because if you're going
to
speed up the process or go and do stuff
on a
on a on a
automated system you want it to happen
relatively quick
and instantly second part is i'm going
to talk about why
the instant pc label which happens
instantly basically it says one minute
50c it's almost simultaneously as soon
as you add it it sort of happens but you
give it one minute
just as you go but what makes the
instant pc die
so wonderful for both fluorescence and
mass spec
is the idea that you have both this
procaine in
procainine section which is the
fluorescent section
and also it's coupled to a tertiary
amine and now tertiary mean gives you
lots of
places to actually put positive charges
if you know anything about
electrospraying the more positive charge
you can put on it
the more likely the more ionization
in the positive mode you're going to get
a mass spec and the more signal
enhancement you're going to get and this
is really important when we look
at the at the competitors or we look at
even 2ab
what you can see is in in fluorescence
our instant pc
is higher fluorescence than anybody else
right
even the procainamine itself doesn't
even have as much fluorescence as the
instant pc
whereas the mass spec some of our
competitors are optimized it's
the amine base similar to ours and you
get
the same results in that spec but what
you see is huge
a lot more signal than the fluorescence
as you're showing on the left hand side
and this is really important because you
want that flexibility down the road
because let's say you're going to be
putting it on a manufacturing floor
you're going to be making it
uh in a setting you might not always
have a
mass spectrometer you might want to use
fluorescence or ce or types of things
and that's sort of an area that is
is really essential by this reagent
because when you're using this reagent
you're actually getting the best of both
worlds
now the other part that makes it really
really nice
is that for instant pc
and even some of our other enzymes i'll
show you some instant a b
later we have a full set of n-link
lichen standards in libraries
and these are wonderful because these
allow you to
correlate to cross um
comparisons there's also method
development so you can buy the standard
and it's already a hundred percent
labeled
and that's really important because you
can use it as to build your libraries
you can build it for all the other
things so it's really really nice place
for you to to buy your standards and
your libraries and know you're going to
be successful
so we've talked a little bit about
labeling process we've talked about the
i made it work for everything you've
gone through this process in an hour
you've got your samples
now what do we do what's the second step
of this
this type of analysis the second step
would be to do separation now you want
to separate these glycans so that you
can actually detect them on either an lc
or an lcms
so lance earlier today talked about
using just lc separations maybe
fluorescence or
uv today i'm going to talk about the
same type of separation
using uh plc you could do this
separation on ce
as well you'd have to use the apts die
not the
instant pc die but it does work very
very well in our 7100 ce
or we've seen groups where they're
coming out of more complex mixtures
actually start incorporating a 2d lc
approach to get additional separations
we're not going to focus on any type of
advanced workflows today with 2dlc
but realize it's a wonderful option for
users wanting to get even deeper
into let's say their proteome or their
actual proteins they're looking at
um and uh where did i want to go back
there
and additionally we have lc columns
specifically for
every one of these critical body
attributes and specifically for glycan
profiling so
the net this slide shows you just an
overview of all the bio columns
um that um we have we have a few others
that
have come along recently this slide
isn't 100 complete but the part i want
you to look at is the red area that says
glycan analysis
and glycan analysis which is a
hydrophilic
interaction type column helix we have
two types of columns we have a
traditional zorbax rapid res helix which
is wonderful
300 angstrom columns it does very nice
job
but we built in the last few years this
advanced bio
like in mapping columns and i think lans
talked about it earlier if you listen to
this talking about the details about it
we offered a 1.8 micron which is a
totally
uh uh porous
molecule we also offer a 2.7 which is
superficially porous
um a lot of people most people i know
use a 2.7
superficially porsche you get wonderful
resolution superficially portion because
of its
you're only going into partial of the
bead you're actually getting resolution
that
in many cases outstrips competitors and
others 1.8 microns so it's a really
wonderful column
to use and the reproducibility uh
as far as you go and here you can look
at the data here the benefit of the 2.7
column is that you get wonderful
separation
and it's superficially porous and then
if you go to 1.8
now you're talking about it small enough
so it's fully porous and the benefit
there is speed if you want to go really
really fast
the nice thing is if we're going to
couple this to a mass spectrometer which
i'll talk about later
the speed is something that a q top mass
spectrometer
can take advantage of when we think
about uh trapping type
mass spectrometers the faster you go the
more difficult they have to
the quicker they have to take scans and
ultimately the lower resolution they're
going to get
excuse me and again what i'm showing
here
is sort of the sample prep portion going
into a column
so if you do good sample trans prep with
instant pc
what you can easily see is uh with our
columns
here the advanced bio columns you're
able to separate all the high mannoses
all the very different mannose compounds
as well as
also the standard uh g0 g0s g1f
all relatively quickly and then you can
run the standards on top which is an a
and then b you can actually see
something like embroil and you can
compare that to where the standards are
and then finally you can see herceptin
and you can see it's
its standard profile and that gives you
a really good uh
idea of how they work as well as you can
see
since we're using a smaller column a 2.1
by 100
and flowing relatively fast on our uh
plc because the beats can take it
all we can do these separations in a few
minutes three to four minutes which is
really exceptional
in order to actually detect the mass
spec which we're going to go into next
in this type of time frame you do need a
really fast
type mass spectrometer and that's sort
of where we get into
the 6545x advanced bioqueutis
this system will let you do intact
proteins and rebecca's going to show you
our intact protein where you can detect
various
glycoforms of the intact molecules you
can also do a whole rich
set of peptide mapping and post
translational modification
confirmation as well as you can do
wholesale protein type analysis on this
on this system and lastly what i'm going
to spend time
and the rest of the talk is sort of this
glycan profiling so we've
released these glycans we know how to
separate them but how do we use the mass
spec and how is this mass effect
specifically designed
to do this release glycan workflow so we
think about what makes this system
really unique and
wonderful is that all other
qtos on the market use traditional
vacuums at ten to the minus seven low
ten to the minus 7. what we've done in
this system is put an
ultra low turbo uh pump in there which
allows us codes
down to low to mid to 10 minus 8. and
because we do this
it allows us to get additional protein
spectral clarity
so for intact protein it really helps
with peak to hump ratio but what it also
does is it keeps molecules much cooler
and it reduces any kind of packets that
go up there
of seeing or interacting with the gas in
the in the flight tube
and because that allows you to see lower
abundant
uh proteoforms and lower abundant
molecules
that you normally would see so it
basically reduces the noise
that you would see traditionally from
each packet coming and spreading out
the other thing is we have large
molecule detections for monotone we also
have small molecule detection autotune
and i'm going to talk about a separate
feature
that we're going to use in the autotune
that's specific for release glycans in
the next slide
additionally quickly you can do really
large molecules and you're intact so you
can go up to 30 000 mass to charge which
means you can do molecules well over
um you know hundreds of thousands over
you know up to them you know say you
could even go into the megadomes
potentially
uh with the system if you found the
right molecule uh because you can put on
multiple charges on those molecules so
you have plenty of range
but additionally you can quickly change
and have the thing the system tuned for
small molecules
so you don't need to change anything you
just hit a button it tunes the system
and the rail for small molecules or
tunes system from our large molecules
and you go back and forth depending on
your samples
we also run proteins at the install
which makes it really a wonderful
product
to test so that you know you're getting
the right results
day in and day out and you know that the
system we
deliver to you can analyze proteins and
we give you quick start methods we walk
you through the process of doing the
digestion
of doing these kind of workflows so that
again
it's not a black box the idea is to
teach you how to use the system
and feel very comfortable with it and
lastly if you're going to be doing
biomolecules
on these systems one of the things you
have to think about
is that when you're dealing with
biomolecules they're salt loving
and they also bring in lots of other
contaminants so what happens is that
you're
using the electrospray on these systems
you can be contaminating the source
relatively easily
and as you contaminate the source your
signal goes down and reproducibility
goes down
what we have is really is we have
actually what they call a gate valve in
the system we can flip the gate
pull out the capillary without
venting the system having to pump it
down at losing its its
vacuum put a new capillary in and that
can happen in a few minutes
and you're back up and running um almost
all other systems out there
uh that do not use gate valves when they
have to vent the system to clean their
interface
it takes you another day or multiple
hours to get back up and running so if
your friday afternoon you say hey my
signal is dropping
what am i going to do well maybe you'd
have to come in on saturday or you'd
have to wait till monday
and aren't supposed to be able to do
that you quickly fit the flip the gate
valve
put a new capillary in flip it back up
and continue to running and get great
sensitivity and results for months after
months day after day
finally the neat thing about our
advanced bioq top is we have this
specific
tune mode and we're using this swarm
model to in swarm is actually an
algorithm it's an advanced ai algorithm
actually that's
built after the way uh birds swarm
to find food and find water and those
kind of things
and because of that it can find the
maximum
or the maximum signal in a very complex
uh setting and if you think about
although the
the actual lenses in the system and all
the voltages
to actually individually tune these and
optimize it yourself
right can take hours and we've actually
done this we've taken
engineers and had them tune the entire
rail to the best of their ability
and then collect data and then what we
had is the swarm autotune collect and
the
ai and the ai always wins the ai is just
clearly better it doesn't much faster
and it's just better we're coming to the
age where
clearly computers have the ability just
like in chess matches to win every day
and because of that what it also can do
is tune this system in the top
for what we call fragile ions and that's
important because when we make these
glycan structures these release
glycans these are fragile molecules if
you don't treat them well
through our interface and you bring them
in too hot
you'll actually fragment them and break
them apart and you won't actually ever
see them
you won't actually see the signal so
you'd actually under represent some of
your ions
and we don't want to do that we want to
make sure that from the time we
take that sample and put it through our
process of both labeling
digest i mean digestion labeling
separation
and mass effect that we're not actually
imposing any conditions on it
and that we're seeing exactly what was
in that vial so that's one of the really
nice features of this you just click
fragile ions do it
and in five ten minutes your system's
set up to do that so here it is
additionally here's some data and the
one thing we get asked all the time
is that how does the fluorescence and
mass spec compare to each other so i'm
going to do both
well here's in line we're actually
showing the the fluorescence in a
and b zoomed in and c and d is the mass
spec and what you can see
instantly is that whether you're doing
fluorescence or mass spec
the signal from both and the peaks are
identical
and that's a really important feature
with the instant pc
die and that's really important a lot of
times with the if you use
instant p if you use other dyes that
don't have as
good of fluorescent signal in some cases
like our competitors
or use 28v which doesn't have a great
mass spec signal some of these small
peaks let's say at like 24 minutes or so
23 minutes they'll be gone in the
fluorescence or the mass spec
and they won't be in bulk and that's the
nice thing about the instant pc dies
that you're going to
see the same fluorescence same in mass
spec and here's an example using the
nist
monoclonal antibodies the standard
anybody up there and we actually have a
publication an
application note that'll take you
through this entire process
of looking at the the nist map
and for nist the nice thing is it's
since it is a standard protein
that the the mist produced it has listed
all the glycans and the percentages of
glycans that are in every in its
standard
samples and what we show you here is in
less than 30 minutes we hit
every single number exactly on so we
know
that not only we're getting great
labeling we're getting reproducibility
but both in fluorescence and in our mass
spec we can get the
results that's expected day after day
oh and here's an example using a sigma
map
so sigma's got a a a monoclonal they put
out there as well
and this is based on only 0.5 micrograms
a very small amount
of this antibody and you can see
regardless of doing fluorescence or mass
spec
you can see the same results as well and
that's another application note
now the neat part about our systems when
we do mass spec
is that when you look at a release
glycogen and here's the g2f one of the
released glycogens labeled instant pc
what you're going to notice is again
like i said the
biomolecules are salt loving so what
you're not only going to see
is high resolution data for the g2f uh
peaks or molecule which is at a thousand
right doubly charged so it's roughly
uh 2048 is the mass you're actually
going to see that molecule
at 1035 and 1043 which are the same
molecule but with a sodium adduct
or potassium atom and sometimes you can
even go down further and see two sodiums
are sodium and plus potassium
now what's really unique unique about
our software
and i'll talk about it later is our
software actually takes in account
all these molecules and actually the
blue lines that you see here
are actually what is actually the raw
spectrum in the red box is we actually
theoretically predict what we expect to
see
and you can see how well our q-top
and our system um represents those
isotopic patterns
so you're not just using one mass you're
using the entire isotopic pattern
to recognize the molecules and that's
really important and q toss do this
exceptionally well it's one of the
advantages of qtos over trapping type
instruments
is the ability to get isotopic fidelity
and i can't stress that enough
especially in small molecule work
of that the ability to do that the other
part i can't stress enough about our
systems
is not only being able to see the peak
of the
m you know the m plus 2h but this being
able to also
bring in the sodium potassium adducts uh
into your total measurement summing them
all together into one
molecule is really important because
what happens if tomorrow your sample
slightly more
sodium than previous day for some reason
right well if this peak
doubles in size and you don't account
for it then you might be off by
20 in your quantitation from day to day
if you're only using one peak a lot of
software only use one peak
we actually take into account not only
the the
the labeled peak but it's sodium and
potassium adducts so it's a really
important feature
and i don't want to minimize that
part and here is a great example of our
software and i'll sort of get into the
software
in a minute looking at the nist antibody
and not only
uh identifying all those but labeling
every single one
of the the glycans and some very
difficult ones
to do as well
with our instant pc and getting very
confident assignments now assignments
are done through
a library that i'll show in a minute and
it's done through
accurate mass and that's one of the
other important parts of having the qtof
is that you can get that kind of
accurate mass with isotopic information
again we can look at embryol and here
you can see
if we look at enbrel i showed data
earlier but you can see the fluorescence
in the qtos
identical and here we can extract out
over here the very small peak demand
five peak and you can see it's got only
the
m plus h and you can see the sodium peak
now is about 30 40
so you put those two together and you
get the total amount of embryo
in there as well now before i move on
to actually showing sort of software i
did want to mention that there is groups
out there
that still traditionally and maybe
filings already done with 2ab
and research past other groups have done
traditional 2av labeling neat thing is
that our gly x to a b
express workflow we can still rapidly
label and get the same results for 2ab
obviously um here's the here's the
workflow similar in ford's instant pc
and what you can see is the nice thing
about 2ab
compared to in our instant pc is that
the results are going to be the same
and here on the top you can see rituxin
of both the 2a be labeled
and retoxin being an instant pc
and what you can see is that the results
are identical
and the cvs among both of them are
identical of an nf4
so regardless of how you're labeling
you're going to see the same results
on both of these two now where the thing
differs
is when you actually look at the
molecule 2a b and you take it to the
mass spec
and this is sort of what i got under
early earlier
is on the left hand side you can see the
fluorescence looks wonderful
but when you go to actually look 2ab in
on a on a qtof what you're going to see
is the signal is going to be a lot lower
and this is for 0.5 micrograms whereas
if you use
instant pc which is shown on the right
hand side you can see
that the top is the fluorescence which
is identical to the
fluorescence of 2av and on the bottom
you can see this the signal enhancement
by amazing instant pc
so again the instant pc is an investment
in your future it's an investment in
being able to add mass spec at any time
with great signal additionally we talked
about column options
and we have a variety of different
methods we can do and i think we can go
further if you want to know more about
columns for 2ab you can use the same
advanced like in map in helix column
but lance and earlier talked about the
variety of different ways we can
utilize these columns either further
separate things out
or do things relatively rapidly rapidly
in runs and lastly before we move on to
actually data analysis
is to talk a little bit about looking at
uh standards and again we have a whole
set of standards this time
every single one of those standards
labeled with 2a b
so you have a set of standard for 2ab
you have a set of standards for
apts which can be used for ce as well as
a whole set of standards for instant pc
so again having these standards and
libraries at your disposal really makes
method development and quantitation
easy intractable for you
so last step you've collected this data
you've done all this work
and the thing you don't want to do is is
have to sit there for
hours doing data analysis it's sort of
like collecting
photos from your phone and then having
to spend hours in photoshop
in order to show them some someone those
kind of data
right and that's where our mass on our
bio confirm software comes in
our mass fund bio confirm software
because you're doing routine analysis
like uh release glycans we
know the optimal parameters for our
systems we know what
we're going to ask you some simple
questions here in the input
what is your protein sequence right in
this case you don't need protein
sequence you just have to say
what is the glycogen label you're using
right and some additional experimental
conditions did you
you know why did you what did you reduce
with uh what did you
de glycosylate with as well as how many
samples you have right you're going to
put in all that
in there you want to compare the samples
so very simple
you can put it in a couple minutes and
the only thing the system does is that
then knows what label you used
and it knows what samples you use it'll
go through and do
all the peak picking it'll use what we
call
uh pcdo and i'll get into that the
personal compound database
library well that specifically has
glycans
are all the human glycans in there
and it'll match up the data and output a
beautiful report
both in pdf format or it can even email
it to you
and because it does this so easily in
this one-stop
process but actually we see many groups
paired this solution with an additional
software we offer which is called mass
on our walk-up
and walk is a software that sits on top
of your system and now allows
one analytical chemist one or two
instrument specialists to actually set
up the instruments
so you can set up the instrument and say
i have a set of group of users that want
to just do intact protein i have another
set that wanted to
release glycan and peptide mapping and a
third set that maybe want to do a small
molecule
right and what i can do is set up my
system so that the only thing they need
to do is drop off the sample
into the system and put a few of those
instrument parameters i showed you
earlier and the system will actually
just automatically run the sample
process the data and then email the
report
and anytime a flag throwns it throws a
text message
to or a notification to the specialist
say hey something went wrong
sometimes that happens or other types
you know buffers are getting low you
need to replace them
you need to fill them back up those are
the kind of messages that would happen
you can also determine priority so let's
just say if you have a really high
priority project you can give users a
certain set of users priority
and their samples as soon as they put
them in there will automatically move to
the front of the queue
so you know your friends can buy you a
drink and get the priority access um
additionally like i said it the software
will do
all this kind of data analysis and this
sort of an intact but
data analysis behind the scenes so the
only thing you need to do is drop off
your sample
now if we talk about the release glycan
and what's behind the scenes
of the software what it uses it uses
accurate math database and
because it's accurate mass on a q-top we
can actually match the formula and again
i showed you those isotopic peaks
because we have such great isotopic
information we can predict
the accurate mass and its exact chemical
formula
to you know the third decimal and we can
match that up
to parts per million in sub parts per
million
and then once it knows the the molecule
and the accurate mass
as well as the tag the software can run
this
this technique called find by formula
and it uses the formula here from the
accurate mass
as well as the features you expect with
sodium potassium adducts
to find all the peaks and it takes all
these peaks and puts them into what we
call
biomolecule table so biomolecules not
just that molecule itself but it's all
its adducts put together into
one sum mount and it makes this table
and this table then
you is interactive you can also export
that table to do additional results
but because in the past the earlier
versions we just had this table users
were saying well
what if i want to know the percentage of
glycogens between each other
well now we have newer results
that actually let you do relative
quantitation between them and i'll show
you that next slide
actually before i'm showing you sort of
the table at the at the bottom of the
slide
but what you can also see is we click on
one individual biomolecule
you'll actually see where that
biomolecule is in multiple runs
you'll actually see an extracted ion
chromatogram
here in the upper right hand corner
where it's showing you exactly at 3.5
minutes where it came off
and then if we look in the left hand
side you'll see its spectrum
and where it's actually picked the peaks
and the blue peaks you can't even see
here because it's accurately found them
and the red peaks being the isotopic
peaks
and then finally in the middle part you
can actually see it shows you
uh one of the structures of views
a glycogen structure view a very simple
glycogen structure view of what it
should look like
and that's sort of the standard view but
if you want you could click on a view of
a few of these
biomolecules say let's compare them and
what this software will do
now is take the areas either by area
or by peak height you can do it either
way
choose the glycogen you're interested in
here you can look at all the glycans
and you can say okay what's the
percentage of
g0f to g0
and here you can see 34 percent of the
total molecule of all the intensity is
g0f and almost none is g0
so you can quickly get a histogram the
other part about these histograms is you
can actually not only do histograms of
one sample you can do multiple samples
so you can do histograms in a single
sample
you can also compare that same histogram
across multiple samples and here's an
example where i'm taking two samples
and looking at the g0f over on the right
and you can see in one sample it's at 53
percent
and the other is at 30 and all of a
sudden
that sample its g1f is also lower
but look at the i think it's g3
and n4 s1 is up to 34
so that's the majority of the molecules
now have that
uh very specific modification
or that release glycan and finally nice
thing about i showed you earlier with
the walk up or any of the software
in bio firm is we have complete reports
that are customizable
and they're really easy they're they're
just drag and drop if you're interested
in having specific tables or structures
you just drag in that you want to report
each of the biomolecules extracted out
as shown on the right hand side
if you want to put a table in you just
drop the table directly in
and you can also choose which parameters
you want so with within
a few minutes you can set up a report
you can change the header to put
whatever kind of header you want
information in there and then once you
set up the report it'll automatically
remake those reports
and automatically report out pdfs and i
showed you earlier with the walk up
it'll actually even the future send that
report
through an email to your uh
to your lab scientist who immediately
can get his results look at his report
in a very
understandable format and actually do
something with it additionally besides
the reports it will produce exports
tables so if you want to put it in a
table x an excel format or put it into
uh your lym system we can interface with
that and upload
data to a limb system which now in our
agile limb systems can actually take it
and do additional data analysis or store
it for the future
so that's the complete comprehensive
workflow
i hope that gave you a good
understanding of how we actually
approach
released glycans and it's not just a
label
it's not just the automation it's not
just a column it's not just a
mass spec it's not just an lc and it's
not just software
it's everything comprehensive to make
workflows
and i think that's really important that
when you invest with agilent and you
invest in the solution you're getting a
team behind you that's thought about
each step of the process
to make this easy reproducible and
robust for you
and additionally i encourage you to go
to our agilent website where we have a
huge number of application notes
brochures
guides on-demand webinars or even
go back and listen to other webinars
whether we teach you
how to do this and um i'm happy you came
today
and hopefully you have some wonderful
questions and feel free at any time you
can find me on the web
or linkedin or stuff if you have any
questions in the future feel free to
reach out to me
i'm happy to help make your bio process
or your bioanalysis much easier
and thank you for your time
all right that was great thank you dr
colangelo for that very informative
presentation
we now will move to the q a portion
as a reminder anyone in the audience is
welcome to submit
their questions in the q a box
we only have two right now so you must
have been incredibly clear in getting
everything across
our first question i am running ms
of proteins with and without pnga's
f treatment is there a plus one dalton
change when using pngase f
in addition to the molecular weight loss
of the
n-link the glycan
yes so you're going to see yes like you
said when you cleave it off
you're going to see the n-link like and
you're going to see i'm like a standard
muffler weight loss because you're
cleaving it off
but when you use pgnsf you're actually
doing an enzymatic reaction of a
degamination
you're going from asparagine to aspartic
acid so you will have
that plus one change so the asparagine
is at 132 daltons
and the aspartic acid is at 133
so you will see that plus one difference
and the nice thing about a
uh you know qtof is that's basically
you're talking about jumbo jet football
field between those two molecules and
our ability to detect those
two so got it makes sense
um and the other question that came in
is do you offer
any method for o glycans
oh glycans constantly comes up but it's
almost every type of
uh every type of talk you give on
glycans talks about glo
oak lichens stuff like that i can say
reach out to me separately we are
working on solutions
there is known solutions out there we
again we don't have kits or
comprehensive workflows but we are
working towards those
and we're happy to work with you on
those type of processes
again the one thing i talk about with
these workflows is that they're
validated in this sense not not
not clinically validated i want to be
very careful that's a
different total word but they're they're
they're put through a rigorous
process so that we know they work day
after day and that's somewhere we
want to get to where we were we expect
to get to
with olga lichens in the future but
we're just not there yet so
feel free to reach out to me and we can
have a discussion on some of the
the things we're working on as well as
approaches we can take to look at those
locations and i hope that helped
okay great well that was all the
questions that came in so thank you
again for the presentation
and thank you again to the audience for
joining and for
submitting those insightful questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative it will be available
for on-demand viewing but don't miss out
on the other
valuable presentations on our agenda
please visit the event presentation
schedule that you'll find in the
auditorium
so until next time i hope everyone has a
great day